in this course you'll learn the basics
of gdau for game development this course
is perfect for Unity developers
transitioning to gdau but it will also
help people who are new to game
development in General Omar Zaki teaches
this course he is an experienced game
developer and has created many popular
good old courses you'll learn how to
navigate the interface and build a
simple Flappy Bird
game hi my name is Omar and I assume
most of you guys at least close to the
update of this video are here because of
unity um a lot of you guys are quitting
unity and have decided to pick up gdau
and so I have made this video lengthy
video it's about an hour long to help
you transition into gdau this video is
not how to become a game developer it
does cover some basic topics of game
development however this video is mainly
focused on introducing you to the gdau
engine not GDOT whatever they say it is
gdau um so I hope you enjoy and I hope
you learn as much as possible from this
video this video definitely will not
cover most the nodes it is mainly just
how to navigate the interface of gdau
and how to actually get started on your
project hopefully um your transition
from Unity to gdau is not too brutal or
if you're not even transitioning your
just picking up gdau and want to learn
game development this is the right place
for you this again is a complete
beginner video just how to pick up gdau
so I hope you guys enjoy this video and
I will see you at the end of the video
our first step is going to be to get
familiar with the gdau engine and
actually making sure we have all the
assets we need so here we have our
Flappy Bird assets and we also have the
goo engine uh executable file so here
here was my Z file for that I'm going to
delete that I'm going to extract this we
have our file here I'm going to delete
this we're going to launch the gdau
executable we're going to create a new
project I'm going to browse it and put
it in my
desktop going to name this fory
bird YouTube
tutorial here on the left we have three
different kind of renderers now for 2D
usually I use compatibility for 3D you
would most likely want to use forward
and mobile is well for mobile for very
less Advanced 3D Graphics um as you can
see there's a little uh description of
what everything does so let's select
none for the Version Control because I'm
not going to put this on GitHub I'm
going to now create folder because we
see here it gives me an error and is
telling me to create a folder now I can
create an
edit and here we have our fresh project
project now let's take a look at our
interface here on the left we see we
have the file system this is where all
the files that we create with scripts
and scenes and anything else will appear
this is also where we will be importing
our file soon on the top left we see
create node now this will change in a
bit however this is where the node
structure will generally be this is
where I edit and change my scene we can
also see the import tab is also on the
top left and we have a few other uh
settings on the top above that now in
the middle as we can see a giant screen
we see the project tab this is where we
see the actual scene and on the top
right above that we can actually change
it to 2D now on the right hand side we
have inspector node and history this is
the inspector but it's also Al the
property panel usually so when I change
a node or an object in my game the
properties will be on the right hand
side on the bottom we have a bunch of
other useful things as such as output
debugger audio animation and Shader
editor there's going to be a few other
things that might pop up depending on
what node you're using for example tile
map or tile set can add an extra thing
which we will be doing in this
video output is usually for things like
print which we will also be looking at
in a bit all right so at this point we
want to actually import all our assets
so we're going to minimize the screen
like this and we're going to find our
folder so here is our Flappy Bird folder
assets all we have to do it's really
easy we just take it and drag it into
our screen if we make sure we select
this drag it and put it into our folder
it's going to say res we just drag and
drop it and it should import now we
might instantly see a problem now the
first problem we
see I'm going to drag one of these
pictures onto my screen it's going to
turn into a Sprite on the top left here
we see the icon for the Sprite and if I
select it by clicking it on the right we
see that it says Sprite 2D now if if I
zoom in we can see it's kind of blurred
so in order to fix this we have to
change the properties of this now what
we can do I
believe in texture sorry here we go in
the texture property we will go to the
filter and select nearest now if I zoom
in we can see it has become
pixelated however I don't want to do
this every time I import and or add a
Sprite so we're going to set the default
now here by default if we actually
reselect this and click the loop it'll
say inherit now what does inherit mean
inherit is going to inherit the default
project settings now if we go to the top
left and click project settings or
project we see project settings if we
click that we'll go
to down here we can actually just search
up fil
filter and we should find rendering
Textures in the textures we'll find
default texture filter at the moment it
is set to linear we want nearest we
close this we now see if we zoom in it
has become pixelated and the filter on
the right did not have to
change now the advantage of this is if I
delete that and add another uh PNG we
can see that it is proper ly pixelated
and not blurry well the background is
blurry but that's just how the
background is so I'm going to delete
this and now we have imported out our
assets and we have set the project
setting now let's go back into our
project
settings and we're going to actually
change the window so let's clear the
search we'll go to window display on the
left and we're going to actually switch
this to divided by 3 and then divide
this by three and then we're actually
going to switch these so this is going
to be 384 and this is going to be
216 so let's make sure we have these and
on the stretch we're going to go to the
mode and keep it as viewport and then
aspect we're going to
expand and now we'll close this and now
we see that our blue window has changed
now this is essentially a camera if I
were to play nothing's going to happen
cuz we don't even have a scene yet but
we'll actually do that right now so
let's go to create root node we'll
create a 2d scene because we want a 2d
game we need a 2d node as the paper what
that we draw on essentially this is
going to be a piece of paper that we
actually draw on and add Sprites and
nodes and other things to it so let's
contrl s to save I'm going to name this
file world and we see that it is saved
as a TS
CN this stands for scene we also see
here that it's going to be recognized as
other things but we just need it as
tscn we'll save this and now on the left
we see world.
TCN has been saved and if I click it
this opens right it's already open but
that's okay now if I click play run
project or F5 we can select or select
current select we'll open this folder
and we can select this to open it and
now we see our folder or our screen is
right here now if we want to change the
actual size of that screen that just
appeared we can go back to project
settings and instead of switching the
viewport and width we're actually going
to select advanced
settings and here on the
bottom below the viewport width I'm
going to copy this and here under all
the way at the bottom we see window
width override now this is going to be
overriding the actual screen we see this
is essentially the pixel size that we
see and play with in our screen so make
sure we take a look at the top right
here we see that this screen is
approximately 250 technically it's 216
that's what we set it to however if we
go to the window width override and
multiply it by maybe two and then go to
the height width override and then
multiply this by two we now have these
settings and if I click close this did
not change however if I click play our
screen is now a lot bigger so that's all
the override does if you were making a
mobile game for example this would not
matter because on a mobile game the
screen will automatically resize to the
Android screen you have or the iOS
screen on Windows this matters more
because that is the window that we
actually play on
now I will let you play around with
these values do whatever you like but
these are the settings I'm going to work
with now one additional thing if you
accidentally select a different scene to
play automatically here we have run
project this will play the project
completely from scratch from the very
first scene now let's create another
scene let's create this scene just for
the sake of having it so I'll save this
as node 2D if I right click this H here
we go now we have this that says set as
main scene so now if I play it looks the
same but it's now going to be running
the node 2D instead of the world and I I
can actually confirm this by going to
the left when I play I See remote and
local local is the local things that I
edit the remote is the live version here
we have root and it also says node 2D we
can confirm this by saying by hovering
it and it says instance node 2D it shows
us the file path now this is because we
have set this to play this on the main
now I can stop this by clicking this on
the top right or by clicking f8 now I'm
going to close the node 2D go back to my
world and now I'm also going to rename
the node 2D to world all right let's get
started in actually creating something
so the first thing I'm going going to
introduce is something called rigid body
2D now in order to add objects into our
game unlike Unity or some other engines
you might have used everything is
already essentially preset now in order
to add that specific object you want we
go to the top left under scene and click
this plus button or contrl
a now we have this window that says
create new node and all these nodes are
essentially objects here we can see the
node 2D and it's actually organized
quite
nicely most the things that are 2D will
be under the node 2D if I click this I
can see a bunch of 2D objects now
instead of just looking through all this
I'm just going to use the search bar I'm
going to search up rigid body now if I
click the
X it doesn't select it so I'm GNA
actually find it for the sake of
introducing just bodies here we go it's
in the Collision object
2D so here in the Collision object 2D we
see that we have physics body 2D we have
static body character body and rigid
body 2D now rigid body is used for
things like balls or things that need
physic uh physics simulation right so I
think the classic example is a ball
because a lot of engines like to compare
those kind of uh physics and I will just
say right off the bat if just in case
you are from Unity one of the main
differences that at least I'm aware of
of the rigid body 2D in good and just
not even 2D but just rigid body the 3D
as well versus Unity is that the rigid
body in uh gdau actually Sim simulates a
real ball so when you drop a real ball
generally it has momentum and it stops
eventually whereas in unity the ball
will keep bouncing to the same height
whereas in goo it'll eventually stop and
get to the ground essentially now we're
going to create this by selecting the
rigid body 2D and create now here on the
left we see rigid body 2D but we also
have an air on the right now if I hover
this it's going to tell us we just need
a collision shape so let's do that let's
control a or add a node and we're just
going to search up Collision shape now
we have a lot of collisions we need a
collision shape 2D Collision polygon can
also work but Collision shape is a
little easier so let's add that now
let's zoom in to this point because
that's where it is we can see it by
either hovering or just selecting it in
general it's already selected now if I
give it a shape on the right
I'm going to select a circle shape
because my bird is going to be a circle
now we can see there's not really
anything here so let's add our player so
let's go to the left on our files and
add our player so we have three birds we
can add from I'm going to add the red
one we can see that it's automatically
turned into a Sprite now in gdau there
are quite a few ways to animate things
so this gives quite a bit of flexibility
in how we want to do things so we can
either go to animation here and type in
the H frame 4 if we do that it'll take
the frames that we had and turn it into
this now there's something called
animation player which I'm not going to
get into but that will it's actually a
very powerful tool in gdo that helps us
animate various
things so if I wanted to animate from 0
1 to 3 for frame it could do that
however I'm going to do an E easier
method and I'm going to use something
called animated Sprite so I'm going to
go to my rigid body select my rigid body
I'm going to add a node and search up
animated Sprite we see animated Sprite
2D let's
create here it's basically telling us we
need to create a Sprite frame so on the
right let's go to Animation Sprite
frames new Sprite frames click this and
here we have a new selection on the
bottom that says Sprite frames now here
it says default but I can double click
this and rename it to
fly now here it's already automatically
looped but here we have no frames so
let's add some stuff now you could drag
and drop but this adds a frame this is
frame zero that's not exactly what we
want so let's delete that what we want
to do is we want to add these four
frames into this as separate frames and
luckily enough good can do that if we
click this rectangle but button little
thing we'll find that this pops up and
we can find our Sprite that we want to
add I'm going to do the blue one
actually and if we zoom in by holding
control and zoom
in able to zoom in and on the right side
used to actually be on the top but they
changed it so it's on the right I
actually don't like that I like it on
the top but that's okay we're going to
go to horizontal and select one nope
sorry four and then vertical we'll do
zero or one so now we can select all
these and we can see that the numbers
actually correlate to the order so if I
did this it would be a different order
now we can just unselect it all and then
select all and it'll do it like that
that's probably a bit easier so select
all on the top or select none and then
select all so make sure we have select
all and we add all four frames and now
we see all four frames have been added
now I can play test this by just
clicking this play
button and it automatically loops now
what I'm going to do is I'm actually
going to automatically play
this that way it plays on when I play
the game now if I run the
project nothing is really going to show
up so what I'm going to do is I'm
actually going to take my rigid body and
I'm going to move all of it by instead
of clicking and dragging you can see
here I've only moved the Sprite what I
can do is either there's a lot of
options I can either take these two by
holding one of them and then shift and
selecting the other or control and then
I can lock it and now I can select my
rigid body or if I don't want to do that
which I usually don't I can just select
my rigid body I can click this guy the
move mode or W and now I can just move
the rigid body from anywhere it's a lot
easier to move things around now if I
play again nothing that's very
interesting let's find out what's happen
happening most likely it's just falling
before we can even see it
so let's go to the remote and see what's
happening oh I see what's happening
we're not playing the correct thing so
let's make sure we select this as the
main scene and I'm going to delete the
other node that I
made there we go there's our birdie and
as we saw it automatically Falls it has
its own built-in physics and gravity
that it just automatically Falls we can
find it by going to the by selecting the
rigid body 2D and going to the right
side with the properties panel we see
linear and angular velocity we're going
to actually play with both of these in
our script in a bit so I'm going to
unselect those we don't want to select
anything here we see the transform this
just shows us the position rotation
scale and skew skew is actually new in
gdau so if you would like to play around
with that you can see what it does it's
kind of
interesting but I'm going to leave it at
zero um um we're not going to really
play them around with too much so now
what we're going to do is we're going to
actually add a script to our bird so
let's actually rename this to
bird then add a script as you might
assumed the script is up here on the
right or on the left sorry with the
little paper thing that says has a plus
button if I click that it'll prompt me
to attach a note now there's a few
options the language I could change
before there used to be um
don't remember what it was called but it
was like another GD thing um but either
way you can also I believe import C into
gdo um I don't know how to do that I've
never tried it I've never done it but
there are videos out there that you can
find that will allow you to do that if
you prefer C over GD script now I will
give a not warning but I guess just a
general knowledge thing is that GD
script is basically python if you know
python or if you have an inkling of what
python how python works you'll be fine
GD script is very similar to python it's
essentially the same but GD script just
has its own builtin functions which is
very useful which we're going to be
taking advantage of now we see here the
inherits this will actually see what
this does in a minute when I create this
but what also matters is the template
and the built-in script template is
actually new which is cool there's no
template real template for the bird or
the rigid body however for some other
nodes there are some templates but
either way we're going to leave this as
node default for the built-in script
this if I select it essentially I cannot
find the script in my files it is a
built-in script into this node usually
that's not what you want to do
because if I create this let's create it
here we go if I hit control shift f I
can find anything in my file so for
example let's say
rigid it will now show me on the bottom
the find rigid and it'll show me the
things that have rigid in it now if I
had made it built in so let's actually
take this out and delete this script if
I do the same thing make it built in and
let's go to
output and then say rigid nothing shows
up because it's builtin it's a buil-in
script that we cannot search through our
files so let's make sure that we have it
not built in and create and here we have
on the right left as well we have an
unsaved thing this is just the the other
built-in script it's a little wanky
sometimes but we're just going to use
this all right so in our script we want
to take a look at the code that we have
so far because right now it's not much
but what's Happening Here is it's going
to extend the rigid body 2D
which is basically a class which is
rigid body 2D that looks like my headset
is low but I'll charge that in a minute
here we have two functions the ready
function it's called when the node
enters the scene and we have the process
function which is very useful but we're
not going to use that just yet we're
going to create a new function called
function input event this is a function
that checks for any sort of event so if
I print the
event and I go to output on the bottom
left and I play my
game and I start moving my mouse or even
clicking a button on my keyboard
anything this is any sort of event now
the question becomes how do I specify
this to a certain type of thing well I
can say if event is input event Mouse
button then we'll print the event now
this is what this is going to do is if I
restart the game
it will only take something if I click
even if I move my mouse it won't input
that because that's not a mouse button
it is a motion so if I actually control
and left click on this it will go bring
me to the input Mouse button um document
and I can even click the online document
I won't now there's also the search help
and we can kind of look at what this
stuff has I'm not going to I'm going I
already know so I'm going to teach you
so when I look in my game let's restart
this if I left click we see that the
button index is one and the button mask
is one and zero that means I click down
so if I click down once and then release
the button mask is zero if I right click
the button index is two so now we can
actually check for which button I'm
clicking on my mouse and I can do that
by saying if event. button index is
equal to one so we're taking the event
and looking for a property button index
is a property of the event so the event
here is the thing that I printed so this
is the entire event but I only want the
button index and I do that by saying
button index similarly we can do event
Doods or press or anything else you can
even check the position by doing event.
position
okay so now we want to add linear
velocity to our player every time I
click now how can I do that well there's
something called linear
velocity however you'll see in a second
so if we want to change the Y maybe
let's subtract
150 so in Gau when we add or subtract to
the Y y AIS the Y AIS is actually
negative in the upwards Direction so if
I look very closely on the left we can
see that this says 50 here and if I go
up a little bit this says 50 so I want
my bird to go upwards when I click and I
do that by subtracting 150 now let's try
this oh that's a little weird that's not
exactly what I want so what we're going
to do is we actually setting it like
this is very strange now every node not
every node but most nodes have a a
builtin function for these type of
things now this one is set do linear
well set linear velocity to this
velocity now I can't just pass through
ay I have to give it a vector 2 so
Vector 2 is just an x and y coordinate
now the X I don't want it to move in the
X Direction because that's right and
left I only want it to go upwards of 150
now calling self is the same as not
calling self so if I do this it's the
same as saying self dot I just like to
get into the habit of doing self Dot and
then the function just so it's a good
habit so that way you see what all these
things are doing to what right so now we
know that we're setting the self to the
linear velocity now if I
play we can see we have a little bit of
jump it's a little better than it used
to be now to make this a bit more fun
we're going to do the same thing but
we're going to say set angular velocity
to negative maybe let's change this to
negative one and see what that looks
like and now you can see our bird is
kind of flipping I think I'll keep it
tog3 so it's a little
quicker now we can see our bird is
flipping like that so it looks a little
cooler okay we also
you also have the option of playing the
fly animation only when you click so to
do that we can go to our animated Sprite
make sure it's selected we have it here
on the bottom we're going to turn off
the autoplay and we're going to turn off
the loop now what we can do is we can
take our animated Sprite and drag it
into our script and it gives us the path
to our script now what does this do this
essentially gives us access to the
animated
Sprite so now what I can do is I can
call something from that and I'm going
to say play Fly it's going to play this
animation for us now we see that there's
a bunch of other properties that I could
put but I'm just going to leave it as
fly this will work fine so now when I
play my bird is not doing anything and
it's very subtle but now he only plays
the fly animation when I
click cool all
right now we've learned how to animate
access animation
Sprites we've learned how to change
properties now we're going to edit our
scene a little bit let's go to our main
scene and I want to add something called
a parallx background which is up here
parallx background we're going to create
this and what is this well it's
basically a parallx background layer so
let's add a another node and we're going
to add a parallx layer now let's take a
look at how this
works if I take my background I'm going
to add this
one take this background transform it to
1.5 to move it down a little
bit and in case you're wondering if you
want to turn on or off the GD snap which
is useful you can easily do it with
shift G or this guy right right here all
right so I'm going to move this in the
middle and I don't want this to move so
I'm going to put it right there Above
The Parallax layer now in the layer
we're going to add something we're going
to add
our pipe to see we're just going to add
this guy just to test it now you see
when I tried adding it it just added it
over here in the world we want to move
this to be a child of the Parallax layer
all right we now have a pretty
complicated setup on the left we
basically have the parallx layer a child
of the world which is fine because we
are playing in a 2d world we have the
paralic background which is a parent of
these two nodes and the parallx layer is
what we're going to use to move so let's
go to our parallx background and we're
going to add a script we're going to
have it built
in and you don't have to make it built
in but that's so it's up to you we're
going to edit something in our process
function we're going to change the
scroll base
offsetx and we're going to subtract
scroll speed times Delta now what's
scroll speed well we have to give we
have to give that variable like into
existence because it doesn't exist so
let's say variable scroll speed is equal
to zero now in
Gau variables are just called variables
now if I want to specify a specific
variable to a type here right after I
think it's here let's find out together
we can say int like this and this will
specify that it's an integer now either
way it doesn't really matter because gdo
is actually smart and will automatically
kind of assume what this type is so here
when I just say equal to zero it's
automatically assuming that it's an
integer now this is nice but I'm going
to add something called
export we're going to to export variable
scroll speed now what does this do well
if I go back to my 2D scene and I click
the parallx background and I look at the
properties well now I see it says
built-in script and then right below
that it says scroll speed and now I can
change that to 50 or whatever number
you'd like now if I
play our background is moving the
parallx background is starting to move
which is great that's really cool
so this is pretty neat one more thing
that's usually used in parallx
background is called mirroring now if I
want the same background to show up I
can mirror it by maybe giving it 100
usually you want to give it the same
number that is this one so
26 zoom out and now if I play it should
duplicate so forget the bird we don't
need
him have that one that's the second one
and there we go there's our third one
right even though we didn't draw a third
one it is now showing up in our game
right and it's going to keep mirroring
forever so that's very useful but that's
not exactly what we need but it was a
good thing to see what this is now let's
delete this parallx layer and we're
going to add something called a tile map
now gdau is actually pretty unique in
their tile map because it's really it's
a really power ful tool than not many
other engines have so in our tile map we
see tile set on the right side up here
it says empty so we're going to click it
and give it a new tile
set now on the bottom we have tile set
and tile map in tile set this is where
the editing happens any sort of editing
to my tile map is going to happen here
any sort of application that I actually
put into my game will happen in the tile
map hopefully you understood that if not
that's okay we're going to learn this
with an example so clicking our tile set
on the bottom we're going to take
the tile style one because this is the
ground and we're going to drag this in
we're going to click yes and we're going
to scroll down a little bit and we're
just going to take a look at here
now the do 4 I actually just changed
this so it's a little
I don't know if you want to call it
easier or harder but it's really cool so
pay close attention we're going to go to
the top right we're going to click tile
set on here we're going to click this
tile set now this these new properties
will show up and we see physics layer
and a bunch of other things the only one
we're going to focus on right now is
physics layer we're going to click add
element and this has basically allowed
us to create a physics layer so now
we're going to unel select that and
close this we're going to go back to our
tile set because remember if we want to
edit anything from our tiles we have to
do it in the tile
set right so now let's go back to paint
actually I'm going to give a quick
demonstration as to why we need to do
this let's go into our tiles into tile
map so make sure we're in tile map and
we see tiles here we can select a tile
and now we can just draw now okay if you
have move mode selected it won't allow
you to draw you have to have the select
mode selected and now we can see the
tiles right there so let's draw along
the map and let's maybe put this one now
we can also paint or use a rectangle
like this to make it a little easier or
quicker will make this easier for us now
if I
play what's going to happen well my
player just fell right through that's
not what we want we want an actual
physics layer now in my tile set again
we're going to go back to the tile set
we're going to go to paint paint
properties and we're going to select the
physics layer right here we have physics
layer now if we did not create that
physics layer you will not see this if
you did not see this physics layer
please go back you missed a step okay so
let's click this physics layer and now
we have some things here let's drag the
up a little bit so we see everything now
here it's actually very neat because we
can specify the physics um layer for all
of these tiles now I'm just going to
select all of these because it doesn't
actually matter but for future reference
you can actually change these points and
change the
Collision see that very cool so I'm not
going to go too much into detail about
tile Maps there are I actually have a
relatively good video on tile Maps it's
about 23 minutes long and you can check
it out is I it's in my channel somewhere
you can find it um but um there are a
lot of tutorials on to Maps so we're
going to just do this and let's play
Let's see what we have
now bam he hit the floor but we can see
that there's a little Gap why is that
happening I want you to try to take a
guess as to why this is happening so
pause the video and try to figure out
why there's a little Gap there hopefully
you've unpaused
well if we scroll down into our bird we
see that the physics layer of our bird
is this big so it it's working how it
should so if we select our Collision map
shape we can see here if I try to drag
this up and down it's not working very
well and that's because we have the grid
snap turned on so let's turn that off by
clicking shift G or just clicking that
and let's pin this down to fit our bird
properly cool so now when I
play it works as it should awesome all
right we now want to add a way to detect
if we hit the floor or the pipe in the
future so right now we have the tile map
called tile map we're going to rename
this to
walls this is going to represent the
walls or the the floor in fact actually
I'm just going to rename it to floor I
don't know why I renamed it to wall but
FL is probably more appropriate now in
our bird we're going to add a new node
called area 2D so if I add a new node
add this node called area 2D and now
it's part of our bird and then we need
to add a collision shape which we can
actually find in the recent as well or
you can just search it up whichever one
you
prefer now we see that it needs a shape
so let's actually Zoom in here because
this is important when we play with area
2DS with Collision shapes with the
actual body or rigid body if this area
2D is smaller than this Collision box or
the same size I believe it becomes
inapplicable and it basically can't
detect anything so you have to make sure
the area 2D Collision is bigger than the
Collision shape of the actual rigid body
okay let's zoom out and now in our area
2D we're going to go to the top right we
have inspector and then something called
node now node is where all our signals
will be there's also something called
groups but there are a lot of videos
about that and you can check that out
groups is uh completely separate from
not from signals but we don't have to
worry about it right now we're going to
focus at the signals in general so let's
take a look at what sort of signals
exist first of all it's important to
note that these signals here are all
specific to the area 2D these are
built-in signals or functions specific
for area 2D now there are other signals
that are general for other things like
node or canvas item or Collision object
or object on the bottom and in fact if
we go to our bird and select this bird
instead we see there's different signals
but these are all the same that's
because they all inherit the same type
of node now let's go back to our area 2D
we want to connect a body entered this
will basically look for anything with a
physical body you can see you can read
it and it says tile map in there so
we're going to double click this and if
it'll actually
automatically prompt us to select this
the script of the bird now if it prompts
you to select something else we make
sure that it's prompting us to send the
signal to the bird let's connect connect
it now we have this signal so what is a
signal what what is this thing well when
this bird and the area 2D specifically
the area 2D hits anything the signal
will proc whenever a b body enters
whenever a body enters this area this
signal will proc and basically get and
say hey something happened right and
what do we want to do well first let's
print the body let's see what it says
let's print the body. name because the
name is actually a property so here we
renamed it to floor it should print
floor if we hit the floor so let's play
and see what
happens ah so it says floor and bird but
why does it say bird well that's because
the area 2D actually collided with the
Collision shape as well so what we're
going to do is we're going to add a if
statement that says if the body. name is
equal to floor then we're going to Q
free this is basically going to delete
our player our
bird oh there he goes he got deleted
cool we have a relatively somewhat
working game with no pipes and we can
stay alive and it works pretty well and
if I hit the floor I die all right so
let's start adding some pipes because
well this isn't fun without any pipes
right so let's take a look at how we're
going to add this pipe well I want to
actually add a new tile
map and in this tile map we're going to
go to the tile set new tile set click
this go to tile set here and we're going
to add whichever pipes you want there's
this one I'm going to add this one and
there's also this one which you can add
I suppose I don't know uh actually I'm
going to add the bottom one because I
think that's the one I used in my
reference so I'm going to go back here
and delete this by clicking this and now
I have the pipe style actually one more
time it
should now one thing I will say is you
will notice the ID changes and this is
important for later but at the moment
I'm just going to make sure that the ID
is
zero to stay
consistent okay now we see here that the
tile set is a little weird it's a bit
different now what we want to do instead
is we actually want to change
the X and Y texture and we can do that
by going down here and typing 32 oh no
sorry 32 for the X but 16 for the Y and
now we can select this entire thing we
also want to do the same thing for the
tile size up here so we're going to say
click
32 now we can select a tile like this
now let's go to tile map and add it we
can see that we can actually add a
tile right so I can do
this can delete it by right clicking
let's add a long pipe
here
that and we
can do that and now we have a pipe let's
also add a physics layer now I want you
to try this remember how we added the
physics layer and added the Collision so
I want you to pause the video and try
this and give it a
try P an
element tile set we're going to go to
paint physics layer we're just going to
select all of
these you can see here that we can even
edit it here I'm not going to care too
much about the tiny Collision here like
you could do this if you'd like if you
are very specific about
it I guess I just did that but yeah so
you can do that and now the is very
specific all right so now we have this
tile map that doesn't move right because
if I play it just stays there now
usually you would think that we want the
bird to move forward but what we're
actually going to do is we're going to
rename this to pipes and then we're
actually going to attach a script to
this we're going to not make it buil in
this time let's create it and in our
process function we're just going to add
something very
simple we're going to say
positionx minus equal 60 which is
basically speed time Delta now let's go
back to our 2D script or 2D scene and
play now we see that our pipes are
moving it looks like our bird is moving
towards the pipe but the pipe is moving
towards us and I collide with the pipe
now what we can do is go back to our
bird and add I want you to try this add
a check to see if you can destroy the
bird when you hit a pipe pause the video
give it a try and unpause when you're
done or confused all right so all we're
going to do is I'm going to duplicate
this and type in
pipes now when I
play and I hit the pipe my bird goes
away cool so in our script we actually
want to
randomize this now how can we randomize
this well I have created a relatively
complex script that you probably
shouldn't do but I've decided that I'm
lazy and I don't know I just like doing
it this way so let's um take our pipe
and we're going to actually Save branch
as scene nope wait
yes yeah I was right
okay we're going to save the branch of
scene and now this thing appeared says
open an editor but what is that what
does that mean well what we can do now
is we can actually take this and delete
it now don't worry it's not gone we've
actually have it over
here now in our pipes we can see that we
have our pipes but over here it's not
here so first of all we want to be able
to spawn in these pipes and then we also
want to randomize the
Gap essentially
now let's look at the randomization
first because that's a little lengthy
you don't have to understand the code
too much but basically first of all we
have to Let's remove the tile set or the
Tom up here let's go to our tiles or
pipes now we're going to randomize this
in our ready function so first we're
going to
say set the top pipe and then we're
going to create a random variable
between 1 and 15 and we do that by
saying variable random range top is
equal to Randy range 1 to
15 and then we're going to for
Loop in range of Randy range top now I'm
going to show you another way to for
Loop but this is one way and then we're
going to do something called set cell
this is going to set the cell on our map
with a bunch of these numbers now what
do these numbers mean well let's take a
look so if I say set
cell sorry about that we have a bunch of
inputs we have layer coordinates Source
ID and a bunch of other things now if
you want to understand this more in
depth again I have a really good video
about this on on tile maps that you
should definitely check out TI maps are
a bit I wouldn't say complicated but a
little more advanced and it can get very
difficult to wrap your your head around
it if this is your first time using it
but for the sake of getting this to work
we're just going to copy the code over
and this will set the bottom two cells
and
then we're going to set the bottom pipe
as well by doing this now in this for
Loop we are not saying in range we're
just saying in
15 okay we have this
code if I
play oops I have to play from the pipes
I want to check the pipes if this works
now how can I do that on the top right
there's run current scene this will
allow me to run this current scene which
is called pipes so if I touch click that
we now see this awesome we now have a
randomized pipe let's stop and then play
again to see if it is
randomized it's a little
different cool it's very different okay
so we see that this works if you would
like to try to understand it I would
give you kudos for it um however I'm not
going to go through the logistics of
this again I have a lengthy video about
tile maps that explains most of this
it's pretty neat and it's uh on
isometric tiles as well which is a
bonus but it works relatively the same
so let's go back to 2D let's go to our
pipes we're going to close this for now
we're going to go to our parallx
background make sure this is selected
and we're going to add a new node called
timer in this timer what is this timer
thing that we just added well it's
literally a timer it will just start
whenever we want it to in fact there's a
property on the right that says auto
start I can click on and this will
automatically start it when I load this
scene now I'm going to explain to you
what we want to happen and I want you to
give it a try we want to connect a
signal from this timer to our parallel
background script and then we want to
spawn our wall now let's go look at our
script and create a function called Funk
spawn and I'm going to help you create
this
function and then I want you to try to
spawn them in yourself now in order to
spawn something that is from a separate
scene I I think it's a little easier
than Unity we do something called on
ready variable wall or we'll change it
to
pipe and then we're going to preload it
we're going to say preload and then give
it the path now what is this path well
this is the path of the pipe well I
called it wall in my reference but here
it's pipe so if I take the pipe that I
just created and then I drag it into
this preload it will give me the path
for it alternatively you can also right
click the pipes and there should be copy
path control shift C now in our function
spawn we're going to do something
called variable wall temp and then we're
going to create make it equal to the
pipe.
instantiate and then we're going to say
add child because instantiating it
doesn't actually add it to our Scene It
just creates the object now we're going
to add the child into our scene and that
is it that is it for the spawn now I can
spawn it in the ready function for
example let's create let's do this and
let's see what we
get well there's our first pipe but we
want it to keep spawning pipes right so
how do we do that well hopefully you
figured this out by now but in our node
on the top right of our timer we click
this and there's a node signal called
timeout and you can see here that it's
trying to connect it to our bird but we
don't want that we want it to connect to
our parallx background script so let's
connect that to our paralu background
script connect it and we're going to
call the spawn function when the timer
runs
out now let's play and see what we
get well there we go now we have a bunch
of
pipes o that's not exactly what I
wanted
well let's go to our parallx background
go to our timer inspect and first of all
let's change the weight time now the
question is why did the bird not get
deleted when I hit it well because let's
actually play and I'll show you why we
can look to our remote and we go to our
world paralex we can see it's we have
pipes but then it's adding a bunch of
other things that just says tile map so
I have 1 2 3 four five whatever well
that's not what we want we want to make
it equals the pipes so let's go back to
our parallx
background and we're going to take our
wall temp and we can actually take the
name which is a property and rename it
to something we're going to rename it to
pipe now or pipes now this might work
let's play and take a look in our remote
section doesn't seem to work now why is
that the reason why it wasn't working is
because in our pipes we were renaming it
every time to the same thing but it
wouldn't do that because we already had
one that existed with the same name so
what's an alternative well we're going
to use something called in but first of
all we're going to create something so
in our pipe script we're going to create
something called variable wall or uh
we'll say yeah we'll say
wall now we're going to save this we're
going to go to our bird script and in
here what we can do is we can say if
wall I think it has to be capitalized
yeah it has to be the same so let's
actually make this lower case and then
we'll make this lower case as well we'll
say if the wall is in the
body then we can Q free now now we can
delete this first of all but this is
basically checking to see if the
property is in that wall that we or the
body that we just collided with so let's
play and now it should work relatively
fine let's test this one more time by
going to the second
pipe and there we
go all
right we are almost done we just have a
little bit more we're going to create
something called a global script now how
do we do this well first of all let's
create a new script we can we have two
options we can either go here right
click oh I guess they removed that I
think we can go to file and say new
script or contrl n or we can go to the
res file on the bottom left create new
and create new script we're going to
create something called game or
Global and in this Global we're going to
remove all this and say
variable
point we're going to set it to zero this
is the points that our player is going
to collect
now in our pipes we're going to create
an area 2D that is going to ding or give
our player a point every time we hit it
so let's create this and add a collision
shape now how are we going to make this
work well it's actually pretty simple we
just have to create a long rectangle
we're going to move this all the way to
the right where the pipe should be and
we're going to make it relatively skinny
now we're going to go to the area 2D and
say if body entered connect this
and we'll say if bird inbody body. name
because the bird is not a variable but
it's the name of our Bird right so now
let's go back to our pipe and we're
going to say
Global do points plus equals 1 however
this should error there we go not
declared in current scope now how do I
make this Global how do I access the
script from this script well on the top
left we go to our project
settings this should open
up autoload we go to autoload right here
this is where we can autoload or
globalize scripts or even scenes so if I
click the folder button this guy will
pop up and you can see I can actually
select the scene too however we're just
going to select the global script and
open this now it says the path we're
going to add it this is the name of the
script to access it we're going to close
it and this should work should
unair sometimes if it doesn't work what
we can do is close this and play it
again or open it and there we go now in
my world we have no way of keeping track
of the game points so let's add
something let's go to our world and add
a
label this label is just a label it's
basically text so if I go to the
inspector and add text I can write a
bunch of gibberish but that's not what I
want I want to create a script onto this
and we're going to say self. text is
equal to string because I'll explain it
in second global. points because we have
to convert this points into a string
because this is actually an integer and
text is a string we cannot set a string
with a integer it has to be a string
okay so this should allow us to show how
many points we have so let's
play and we see on the top left we have
the
points and every time it pass to the
pipe increases the point and if I die it
should not increase the point and that's
it all right that is pretty much the end
of this season series I hope you enjoyed
it and I'll see you guys congratulations
you have finished this video the mini
course if you guys enjoyed this course
or little video I made um please
subscribe uh share the video with your
friends or other Unity developers that
have not transitioned yet um what else
if you guys liked my content um I'm
going to be working on a course coming
up soon is going to be a really really
big course consisting of not only how to
master good D but also game development
and getting started in game development
um it is not out yet most likely it's
going to take me a while to get it out
however if you would like to support me
on that and my development of that
course um I would appreciate it to
either support me on patreon or I will
have a Kickstarter soon so please
subscribe to stay updated on that um
also join my Discord which will also be
in the link down below again
congratulations for finishing this video
it was pretty long um hopefully you can
continue on with this project and build
on it and who knows maybe you can
release it probably not because the
assets are you know flppy bird but
that's okay I hope you enjoyed making
your first game in good d